manifestation tout à l'heure dès 13h30 à
paris point de départ du cortège
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière un
rassemblement à l'occasion de la journée
européenne pour défendre l'accès aux
soins et à la santé et d'autres
mobilisations similaires sont prévus cet
après-midi dans une dizaine de pays
d'europe à l'appel de 60 organisations
des personnels soignants qui réclament
un meilleur système de santé un accès
équitable aux soins ainsi que de
meilleures rémunérations
écoutez à ce sujet noémie ban présidente
du collectif inter urgence et
infirmières dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
c'est vraiment le point de départ de
mobilisation européenne par même
internationale puisqu'il ya nos amis du
québec qui se mobilisent aux soins
aujourd'hui nous aurons la belgique
l'espagne ni tabou qui va être vite
suivie par par la roumanie et beaucoup
d'autres ping on a besoin de retourner
dans la rue aujourd'hui pour que l'axé
vraiment à la santé soit entendu il ya
il ya encore de grosses problématique
qui a toujours de grosse problématique
ça fait deux ans qu'on le crie nous dans
la rue avec le collectif à
l'intelligence les revendications elles
sont pour un accès à la santé pour tous
elles sont pour permettre une
gouvernance pour je vous disais là entre
les soignants les usagers pour qu'ils
aient vraiment leur parole et leur mot à
dire dans la gouvernance des hôpitaux